this story takes place in London in the
neighborhood of East Lambton behind door
number seven on both ream use where
fifteen people are working hard to keep
one handmade tradition alive close close
close
some of the world's last handmade gloves
get made under the guidance of this guy
Peter Beller be let's begin here's our
team there's me Peter Bellamy and I'm
the owner and I have a hand in all the
large globes there's a woodworking team
they make them finish all our bases our
globe makers they turn blank spheres
into Globes
then there's Leah our cartographer
she customizes all our maps our painters
they bring our globes to life and Leah
our apprentice there's a reason why one
of the last making globes is extremely
complicated so ready we make the globe
we draw positioning lines we apply the
paper to the sphere that's the hardest
part we paint the globe we varnish to go
we ship the globe yeah yeah yeah that's
it from start to finish for a small
globe it takes a month the large globe
is will take six to eight months I mean
when I started I gave myself three
months so to two years it is crazy
if I'd known how difficult it was at the
beginning I'd never have done it it's
not logical it's not theoretical there
are no books it's just about patience
practice and perfection I completely
love it
we grow up with glows we see a globe we
ask our parents where are we from what
is it all about they show us and you see
this massive expanse and you're just a
tiny little dot that's not even there it
can help you dream of things it can help
you imagine things the only thing in
life that's intercessory is food and
water but if I was going to surround
myself with with things that meant
something to me a globe would be high on
that list
you